this machine is the upright cycle
firstly you want to adjust the seat to
hip height and then Mount the cycle
putting your feet into the pedals to
tighten the strap you pull the black
clip back and then you can begin
pedaling
to start the machine you press the green
quick start button and then once it's
loaded it'll show a 30 minute workout
to increase the resistance on the cycle
you press the plus sign on the effort
button in the middle
the level is shown as pointed to
RPM is the revolutions per minute
meaning the number of turns in one
minute
this is where you can see how far you've
cycled
to then finish the cycle you press the
red stop cancel button which will then
display a summary of your session
[Music]